are you into social medias is something
that you were familiar with in your home
no no I thought I should probably get on
it for work reasons I was told it was a
good idea so I asked my stepdaughter who
at the time I think she was 16 and I was
like so how do we do this Facebook and
she was like you know honorbound like no
one's on Facebook anymore and I'm like
what she said Instagram Instagram so I
did that and I got Twitter but I don't
I'm really bad at it I'm trying to get
better I don't know I don't get it but
it seems fun I guess there's a kind
following this pig named Barbie the pig
on Instagram why are you following a pig
she's so cute
this woman dresses up her pygmy pig or
mini pig is there a difference I don't
know anyway this pig is really cute and
there's fashion grandpas is another one
I really like this guy takes pictures of
really cool-looking senior men you're
following that and fashion you're
following fashion grandpas is you like a
stylish older man yeah and a little a
strange pig a little pig yeah a little
pig there's a couple others but those
are my two favorites right now it sounds
like you're getting along fine with
social media yeah I have no idea there
was even the thing like a mini pig or
pygmy Pig so I know that now yeah
another thing ya know it's what it was
invented for
you